[Music]  you know New York Wanda we bow down to  green jello blossom the superstar singer  just dropped the music video for her new  Spanish single ill a neo or the ring  it's fiery it's fierce and only et was  on the regal set but it's really about  recognizing your own value I think and I  think that's where women are right now  and all of us being you know knowing  that we are Queens that we are goddesses  and that we should be treated that way  and that people need to give us that  place in their life if they want to be  in our lives  the song has fans buzzing is JLo sending  a subtle message to boyfriend Alex  Rodriguez listen I didn't write the song  I played it for Alex and I was like are  you cool with this I think it's kind of  funny he's like yeah I'm totally cool  with it for more with JLo behind the  scenes of El niño watch ET Friday April  27th I'm New York Wanda way